foreign
[Music]
he's just a day or two old
but this tiny elephant has an enormous
Mission
become the biggest giant that walks the
planet
[Music]
a great bull elephant
but the odds are stacked against it
he'll need to outlast drought
survive deadly predators and poachers
and finally
fight for the top spot
but before he can do any of that
just to learn
to stand up
[Music]
elephants don't come much smaller than
little e but he already outweighs most
men
he's got to get moving his family has to
travel miles every day to find food
[Music]
he needs to stay with them
babies that lose their families don't
stand a chance
[Music]
the first steps aren't easy
but the little guy seems to be getting
the hang of it
[Music]
well one step at a time anyway
it's Mom calling
he's never far from her side
foreign
the little guy for almost two years
but caring for little e is just the
beginning
she has a good 13 years ahead of
comforting and protecting him before
he's ready to leave her side
it won't be easy
up to a third of elephant calves die in
their first year
he needs her to survive out here
but they won't be alone
females in a family stick together to
raise their young
[Music]
it's Grandma
she's head of the family the matriarch
[Music]
seen lots of babies grow up in their 50
odd years
and some that didn't make it
together this family will do all they
can to give little Eve the best chance
he's got
[Music]
this is no place to be alone
this is
part of a Great Wilderness called the
mara Serengeti that stretches for more
than 150 miles across East Africa
[Music]
some of the world's most iconic animals
live here big
and small
[Music]
Little E's gonna have to learn to live
with all of me
[Music]
time of year to raise kids
it's the end of the dry season and the
rains are due any day now
[Music]
they better come soon
a bad drought would make it even harder
for E to survive
without rain food dwindles
and that's bad news for big eaters
[Music]
his mom is going to produce enough milk
for her 200 pound baby
she's gotta keep eating
up to 16 hours a day
luckily she has a babysitter to help
that's little he's on
she looks after him all day long
she keeps him close
and out of trouble
it's great practice for when she has a
calf of her own
[Music]
poor little guy can't get a break
but he can learn a lot from her
like how to conquer an itch you can't
scratch
[Music]
his next lesson
figuring out exactly which set of legs
leads to the milk
easier said than done
not everyone is so patient
[Applause]
it's best to give Grandma a wide birth
she doesn't have much milk
besides it's not her job to feed Little
Eve as matriarch she's responsible for
the whole family
he's got to look at the big picture
and make the important decisions
especially when times get tough
like they are now
for little e that could be the
difference between life and death
[Music]
older elephants like Grandma carry
precise Maps they've built in their
minds throughout their lives and can
remember distant water holes visited
years or even decades ago
today Grandma leads them to something
else
a salt lick
but to get to the good stuff they've got
to dig
[Music]
elephants need vitamins and minerals
just like us
and they have to replenish them
[Music]
Little League gets all the nutrition he
needs from his mom
three gallons a day
[Music]
if the food runs out her milk will dry
up
[Music]
but some threats
are more immediate
[Music]
the Lioness will have to weigh her odds
she's no match for a grown elephant
but a 300 pound lioness against a
newborn calf
little e wouldn't stand a chance
things could turn real bad
real quick
[Music]
the thick bush cloaks the lion
the Ambush is set
mom seems to have clocked the danger
but the Lioness isn't alone
he's surrounded
but the elephants won't put up with the
cats so close to the baby
this is where family comes in
[Music]
oh
better for the Lions to back off and
live to hunt another day
after all they've got little giants of
Their Own
lions with Cubs will help raise each
other's young it's something they have
in common with elephants
[Music]
but competition's tough smaller Cubs
often lose out at meal times and only a
few survive their first year
[Music]
but they're okay for now
plenty of time to practice hunting big
game
or at least big for them
[Music]
[Laughter]
not everyone around here is lucky enough
to have a large family
[Music]
on the other side of the voice show
there's another tiny elephant
but he and his mom seem to have lost
their family
[Music]
the calf looks okay for now
but his moms run down from looking after
him
[Music]
day and night
all on her own
[Music]
they need to find their family
that's her calling for them
[Music]
elephants can recognize one another's
voices a mile away
[Music]
it's a bad time to be on her own
she can't defend the calf from predators
not all by herself
she needs help
and soon
[Music]
Little E's family is on the move
Grandma leads them onward
with the dry season water sources are
farther and farther apart
brings them to one of her favorite pools
but even grandma didn't see this one
coming
the hippos are dug in they aren't going
anywhere
if the elephants wanted to drink from
the pool they could after all elephants
are the biggest mammals walking the
planet
but Grandma decides it's not worth the
trouble
not for a pool full of Hippo dumb
she's always got a plan B
matriarchs are not self-appointed
leaders or simply the oldest
over the years she's made wise decisions
time and time again and her family
respects her for that
especially when she leads them to a
place like this
[Music]
nothing short of an oasis
but they're not the only ones here
other families come to quench their
thirst too
[Music]
the big ones can drink 50 gallons a day
take months before little e can use his
trunk to drink
human hand has 34 muscles to control
Little E's trunk has over 15
000.
[Music]
soon it's time to eat grasses bushes
trees almost any plant they find over
400 pounds a day for a single adult
foreign
[Music]
s have an extra trick up their trunks
how to get to Fresh grass others can't
reach
family can't stay here forever
[Music]
temper is afraid and the food won't last
long
not with so many mouths to feed
[Music]
and this year in the boy show has more
of them than ever
failing rains in the north and east have
kept huge numbers of wildebeest here for
calving season
that means a lot less grass to go around
[Music]
this guy is only a couple of days old
but he's already getting the hang of
those long legs and doing what he was
born to do
run
and when it comes to running will the
Beast can hold their own
they're some of the best endurance
Runners on Earth
and can reach top speeds of 50 miles an
hour
most are born in the same couple of
weeks
and their sheer numbers mean any one of
them has a better chance to survive
[Music]
unless you lose track of your mom
with so many other wildebeest around
it's easy to get lost
there's no teamwork here
other moms won't accept him or let him
suckle
calls scene to go unanswered
but that doesn't mean they're going
unnoticed
the Lioness won't Rush
she knows how to wait for a stray
[Music]
and when to strike
but the calf finds mom just in time
[Music]
and the hunter heads home empty-handed
these Cubs also need protection from
hyenas even other lions
but their biggest threat is humans
it's a good thing she's got her family
to help
back on the other side of naboy show
it's a big day for little Eve
thank you
he's about to meet his extended family
a gathering of some 50 relatives known
as a bomb
great aunts cousins second cousins
everybody it's Little E's first time
meeting them all
when times are bad they'll split up and
spread out to find food
[Music]
but as the dry season gets tougher
families may meet at water levels
it's a bit overwhelming now but one day
little e will recognize his whole plan
and many many more just by their voices
[Music]
this one's Little E's cousin
he lost his tail to a hyena or maybe a
lion
he's lucky to be alive
good thing he had a big family nearby to
protect him
each one of these little elephants will
likely get their fair share of trouble
so they spend time learning how to
defend themselves
and having fun
[Music]
foreign
these guys are running around pretending
to chase off enemies lions and hyenas
[Music]
they're practicing for when they have to
do it for real
[Music]
thank you
these little ones are just goofing
around
it can get a little rough too rough for
a little Eve
he'll set this one out
[Music]
thank you
congratulations
seems we found our winner
by the time they're teenagers the boys
will start spending time with other
families to meet guys their own age
and in their 20s they'll spend more and
more time in loose knit games called
Bachelor groups that wrestling is a way
of strengthening bonds between friends
but also practice for the day they have
to take on a real giant
like this guy
[Music]
and up for grabs
greatest opportunity for any eligible
bachelor
the chance for Romance
[Music]
little e won't get a shot until he's at
least 25.
[Music]
and some bulls will even die virgins
This Guy's in the sexually heightened
State called must
and his body's pumped with testosterone
so he's cruising looking for a partner
[Applause]
it's pretty big so he stands a good
chance
she'll usually pick the biggest bull
still has to win her over
maybe he should just cool down
when it comes to the two-ton two-step
it's lady's choice
in her interest lasts only three days
it's time to pull out all the stops
[Music]
the Bulls got it all going on and it's
working
[Music]
a rumbling says she's excited
it doesn't look like they'll get much
privacy now
elephants the whole family celebrates
[Music]
yeah looks like he played his hand just
right
but the party can't last forever
Without Rain
food is getting scarce
there's hardly enough to satisfy
everyone's giant appetites
[Music]
little e and his family search for
greener pastures
foreign
the single mom and her little calf still
haven't found their family
but they finally catch a break
[Music]
they find water
and it's the first time for the calf
it's great news for them both
elephants can only go four days without
drinking
[Music]
thank you
it's been weeks and the rain still
hasn't come
the Green Plains have withered Brown
this dry season has become full-on
drought
McGee's family have been on the road for
days but they found nothing but dust
thank you
they can't stop here
not now
grandma keeps them moving forward
relief lies in the Hills just ahead
but their way is blocked by what they
fear most
Little E's family needs to go forward
but it's a real risk
people have been dividing up these lands
and building Farms
thank you
sometimes elephants eat the crops they
grow
and that can spell death for the
elephants
[Music]
other times poachers kill them for their
tusks
across the African continent nearly 100
are slaughtered every day for their
Ivory
so Grandma's right to be wary
she's likely seen friends and family
killed by men
but if she wants to lead her family to
food and water
they'll have to go right past the
settlement
even little Eve
[Music]
but what we're just learning is that
elephants can make plans and grandma has
one
they'll wait for the cover of Darkness
until then everyone can rest up
there won't be a chance to stop once
they make their move
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well now
isn't that something
scientists say that elephants can feel
empathy and understand how each other
feel
just like we do
little e certainly looks more
comfortable
[Music]
foreign
time to get into position
it'll be dark soon
[Music]
they join up with the larger Bond group
to make the crossing
safety in numbers
hopefully little e can keep up
no stops allowed in such dangerous
territory
the herd takes their chance
their padded feet muffle each step
you wouldn't believe how silent
elephants can be
and the Coming Night cloaks them in
darkness
[Music]
oh
Dawn
the settlement's miles behind
they've covered a lot of ground through
the darkness
but Grandma may have led them out of the
frying pan
Into the Fire
one of the odds is up front with her
calf they have no idea what they're
walking into
and little e is up next
[Music]
the lions are downwind which carries
their scent away
there's not much light
and with plenty of undergrowth
the cats are well hidden
the family's trapped surrounded by
watchful eyes
[Applause]
thank you
it's Little E's turn to push through but
he won't be alone
mom and her sisters flank him on all
sides
the rocky terrain slows their escape
[Music]
and another obstacle lies just ahead
the Lions could sneak attack little e at
any time
they have to get him to safety
[Music]
he's been on the move for days
last night's Trek was tough on the
little guy
and that riverbed doesn't look like much
to you or me
but a tired and hungry baby elephant may
as well be the Rocky Mountains
[Music]
come on little guy
[Applause]
ouch a 5 000 pound Crush would not be a
nice way to go
looks like Mom's more shaken than he is
but they can't stay here long
[Applause]
not with the Lions so close
[Music]
foreign
Magic
elephants can detect rainstorms 150
miles away
but how she knows is a mystery
it'll turn the boy show Green in no time
[Music]
thank you
soon there'll be plenty of food for
everyone
[Music]
the single mom in her calf didn't find
their family but managed to make it
through just the two of them
[Music]
little e had a whole family behind him
to survive his first drought
[Music]
thank you
he'll need them for years to come
the world around is changing and fast
[Music]
with a family like his this little giant
just might make it as one of Africa's
great bull elephants
[Music]